[musique]
Je veux y aller avec quelqu'un qui aime Ghibli.
Ce que je veux voir, c'est
Après tout ça
par la main
apparaître dans le film
C'était quelque chose
C'est un personnage
C'est un bâtiment
j'aimerais voir le paysage
Je pense qu’il y a des parties qui me concernent vraiment.
Je pense que oui
Le paysage que j'ai vu quand j'étais petite
Regarde-le comme si tu étais vraiment là
Je pense que c'est bien parce que tu peux
[musique]
Le Studio Ghibli ne réalise pas de longs métrages.
Alors, que dois-je faire pour laisser cela derrière moi au collège technique ?
C'est comme Ghibli Park d'après l'idée
Dans certains cas, c'est devenu
Donc
Diverses choses de Ghibli
Emballez-le bien
Pour que beaucoup de gens n'oublient jamais les œuvres de Ghibli
À ce moment-là, j'avais le sentiment que je voulais
Cependant
Je suis encore trahi
Hayao Miyazaki réalise actuellement un long métrage.
[musique]